Back in the
1960s, Jane Goodall,
with no formal training
in science at the time.
I mean, holding aside her
four-year-old exploits.
The fact is, in the
real world, people
look, well, what's your resume?
Where did you get your
degrees in science?
She had no formal
training in science
and she went alone into
the Tanzanian jungle
to study chimpanzees.
Which, by the way, had
never been done before.
So I asked her, how and why
she found herself on that path,
without having any
science background at all?
Certainly not anthropology.
Let's check it out.
So in the 1960s, there's of
course, we're in the Cold War,
we're going to the moon, and
you're thinking about chimps.
I'm desperately trying
to get into their world
and find out about them.
If no one had really
done that before,
then you're not following
in anyone's footsteps.
No, and my mentor, Dr.
Lewis Leakey, you know,
paleontologist, spent
his life searching
for the remains of the
earliest humans in Africa.
So not even he is
looking for chimps.
Or he's looking for
something en route to humans.
His argument was, OK,
about 60 million years ago,
there's an ape-like,
human-like creature,
and if you uncover a
fossil of an early human,
you can tell an awful lot
from the muscle attachment,
from the wear on the
teeth, from the tools
associated with their living.
So you can learn a lot about
the behavior, social behavior.
That doesn't fossilize.
So his theory was if Jane
sees behavior that's similar
or the same between
chimpanzees today and humans
today, perhaps that same
behavior was brought by humans
and by chimps along a
long evolutionary journey,
and originated in that
ape-like, human-like creature.
that's why he sent
me out to Gombe.
But he didn't know anything
about the field work.
He just sent me
off on my own to go
and find out about the chimps.